Eating in Ethiopia is a special experience.
You sit on low comfortable divans covered with monkey fur.
The server appears with a pitcher, a copper basin and towels to clean your hands.
A wicker table with a domed cover is brought, and when the cover is taken off,...
...you see a gray tablecloth overlapping the edges of the table.
When the food is poured onto the tablecloth,...
...you realize that it's not a tablecloth after all.
It's the "Injera," the sourdough Ethiopian bread that looks like a great big pancake.
You tear off a piece of bread with ingredients on it and roll it up like a cigar.
A polite gesture is to stick the roll into another person's mouth.
The idea is not to take the best bits for yourself.
The dishes could be peppery stews like chicken or lamb wat,...
...lab cottage cheese and yogurt.
The dessert may be raw ground beef.